[Music]
do you guys ever catch yourselves being
a little racist you talking to this
[ __ ] place oh my god oh my god
the UN would [ __ ] die if they heard
any of our videos so I recently
discovered that there's this event that
is called race to dinner and so it's
it's being held by a black woman named
Regina Jackson and suryya Roe and who
identifies as Indian American and so
these two women of color they decided to
host these dinners or not host like
chuck at these dinners where a white
woman will volunteer to host a dinner
for seven of either strangers or
acquaintances or her closest friends and
then she blames not a whip and start
hitting everybody all these white women
around the dinner table and that's when
these two women of color start to really
have these white women confronts
themselves with their internal racism
like a confessional kind of only for
white people white women oh man I was
gonna be like let's roll some white
[ __ ] show
that'd be so funny of the two girls come
up and then they just have a dinner
she roasts every single white lady in
their Lobby so funny on their website
race to dinner it says our mission is
simple reveal the naked truth about
racism in America and unleash your power
as what as white women to dismantle it
this isn't the stuff of trunk the KKK
and Nazis that's easy it's obvious and
denouncing it requires almost nothing of
white folks what's hard looking at
yourself in the mirror and acknowledging
that as a white person in America you
are an active participant in upholding
white supremacy what does it make you
bad this is systemic this makes you
human and an integral part of that
system black and brown women are also
part of that system the truth is we are
on opposing side people of color are on
the receiving end of white supremacy
while white women or white people white
women you are on the
giving end until and unless white women
are willing to disrupt white supremacy
we will never see change white women you
have the power to disrupt and dismantle
the hate they took the fun out of racism
no I get it
it's like a conversation with white
women to maybe figure out how they might
be racist on accident they don't even
know it oh yeah so it's like it's like
talk about it and be like yo so you
might not realize this yeah
when you say this so when you do this
yeah it might it's gonna come off like
this you don't even know it grew up in
like a bubble and yeah around minorities
and stuff yeah yeah so for example if
they call they're like unbel yourself I
think they'd be a little bit like it
just already feel sounds like so let me
come over and toxic come in your house
say how shitty you are yeah you better
make me dinner - with so much tension
that it's already like it doesn't feel
like what's a trading of information and
let me better understand do you
understand me it's already like okay you
[ __ ] up and let me show you how much
you [ __ ] up it's all like hey hello
you are white you are a problem oh this
is all about you know when you don't
know you're being a racist but no it's
not that they're saying like you are
what you are a problem a systemic
problem in fact you're like it's like
it's being arraigned is like because
you're white you're a problem so now we
have to teach you a holiday in the map
even though you're a problem so we have
to teach you there's all there's no
we're just reading a lot of white people
that fought with everyone in the civil
rights movement and all Enders there's
just been yeah it's so divisive where
it's like if you're a part of this group
then you're a part of the problem
they're more like over here like a
little bit for the middle and then I
think the way you guys are framing it is
way more on the extreme end of thing I'm
just going by what you read I don't know
anything about so based off of the rest
of the thing that I read is what like it
just seems like they're really Church
trying to have a conversation and then
these women are volunteering to come to
this dinner so they can hear the other
perspective of black and indigenous
women and so they're just saying like
like for example they do start the the
dinner by saying well first of all the
fact that it's a dinner is already
different because they were saying if we
were doing this in a conference room
like people just walk away so the fact
that it's a dinner you're just true I'll
let someone talk [ __ ] to me if I'm
eating food
I'm like dude this is good I'm what yeah
I'm an [ __ ]
massage yeah a little bit yeah
sorry so yes so then they'll go one by
one and they'll ask the question what
was the racist what was a racist thing
you did recently they'll end up
I called them out an n-word and flip
them off no so like for example one of
them said like like you know what when
I'm driving down the street and I see I
see a black person just walking down the
street I lock the doors
eternally I'm saying I'm thinking you
must like fried chicken they're up to no
good
being a black person and having an
assumption that they're up to no good
immediately after that I'm like that's
no good this is a human they're just
doing anything why do I think like that
and then he Rob's you because maybe he
has a gun it is Andy you've gotta have a
black meter - it's like is it is it is
it sister Mary Clarence you know huh
wait wait I heard the reference Oh
sister
sister I said Whoopi Goldberg there it
is or is it like a real thug what do you
you know you got to have a real meter
sister Greg Lance was a badass so this
is about like you know what they call a
micro aggressions you feel me where it's
not like an outward racist like it's not
like a hate crime but it's just like
something that's already in them
for whatever reason and they're like
trying to dissect like okay why do you
think this way like it might be media
like like from the the fear-mongering
that the media plays right their parents
generation yeah yeah that's why it's so
funny though that the idea that this is
only for weight limit yeah there's no
racism between races like our
[ __ ] for sure but the reason
why they're they're focusing on white
women is because they what they're
explaining hair is that white women are
placed in the very close proximity to
white men who are in power and like you
know these white men are their family
their friends their partners whatever so
if they are like feeding more into what
are the systemic racism water they are
in a position to kind of check
themselves and be like oh wait maybe we
shouldn't think like this maybe we can
think about another way because they're
so close to the white man that's the
reason why they're focusing on white
women and not just that but then like
just women like in the group of gender
you know white women ranked at the top
in terms of like stereotypes or racism
or whatever so if they can also help
their like black and indigenous people
of color women of color alongside them
then that will help society in general I
can't read it there because I look if
you got like a like a racist family and
a little and your Grint and the white
granny walks up and she's like we have a
problem then it's like everyone's gonna
listen to white granny you know saying
white grandpa it's like all right
grandpa cool I get it but granny is like
okay if granny's saying something listen
listen to granny you know so they wanna
attack it at the granny and the source
of the source
she called a granny would have to
explain it better she raps about it like
wedding singer yeah yes so this is
Regina and Sariah
right Cyrus I hope I said it right sorry
you know what I was really hoping here's
some more photos of the dinner I thought
it was gonna be a racist Olympics game I
know you know every single culture in
their stereotype right getting them all
out at dinner roasting each other
so far yeah and in the all hug at the
end yeah yeah say the most racist [ __ ]
you got in yet I like that one that puts
the fun back in racism and that's so
much fun again I'm also speaking from LA
California point of view wherever
they're at I don't know where they're at
well they go across like around the
whole country because there are areas in
the the country still that are just kind
of isolated yeah they're in there doing
their own thing they're still segregated
or was here it was taken in Colorado in
Denver so they're saying that these
dinners cost 2500 someone recently um
that got attacked it's good for uh like
a like like some Asian kid got a tag for
from being a corona virus like that you
caught
[ __ ] you have Corona and they
[ __ ] them up ha sucks within they got
cranberries now yeah I know right I mean
[ __ ] always goes down so I guess
whatever people are trying to do to
remedy it it's cool but I kind of see
that so you know even cuz you said like
la it's it's diverse right but even like
going to like meetings in Hollywood like
I remember specifically having like a
pitch meeting to this like older not old
but older white lady who was kind of
like the person I had to meet to get to
like the bigger person and I we had this
whole thing about I was pitching a show
about like interracial relationships
like me I'm like dating a black girl
you're kind of like based on like my
marriage and [ __ ] the whole thing we're
like pitching different um funny
scenarios like okay maybe she's coming
over for dinner my family for the first
time and like stuff smells a little
funny because she's not used to like
that like that whatever my mom's cooking
and so this lady right uh thinking she
was joking Oh like you know bit like
building onto the idea she's like she's
like oh yeah you know that'd be great
like yeah you know that she comes over
for dinner and you guys are cooking like
dog or whatever and everybody in my head
I'm like hmm but in her head she's like
we're just spitballing here you know
said we're just riffing so but in my
head I'm like so when you bring up
something like that or it's like okay
she doesn't think she's being racist she
things like we're just joking around so
I'm like okay I get what they're trying
to do with this you know so cuz like you
know she doesn't think she'd be a racist
she's like yeah that's true I got this
old white lady in my speech class in and
I was coughing she's like are you sick
and she gives me this I write she goes
it's not the coronaviruses it
I'm so sorry that was so insensitive
like that time in this class because I
need to learn like boundaries and then
later we're doing an improv game right
and then we have to try to clap at the
same time anyway we clap at the same
time she goes
amazing shoes off together so [ __ ]
ridiculous
I couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing like we
were like this and she goes oh my god
but she got it right accurate you did
that true hockey he made your head
you're like she's not trying to be mean
no she's like [ __ ] 60 years old like
what do you expect right she's trying to
connect with you but in the most racist
way why she's trying to be funny right
and then I mean there are other Asian
people in the class and [ __ ] and I'm all
like just shaking the head psych you
guys could either get mad at this but
isn't it ridiculous that she's doing
this in the first place she's blind as
[ __ ] and at the end she was like you
know what I just realized
oh I have to know my audience like we're
not longtime friends but I feel so
comfortable around you and she's like
I'm so sorry I did that
and I was like no I don't really care
like it's not a big deal she goes that's
why I'm in these classes like again
connect with me yeah basically she kept
saying that you know I just think she's
yeah make sure it's funny then it veins
okay hold damn yeah all right that was
[ __ ] funny though bro and you came in
the classes you went minute internet
net-net man man
[Music]
[Music]